Joe thanks so much for coming to talk to
us today and telling us the story about
your daughter Rafi
before we get into what happened
I first like to get your reaction to the
inquest verdict the coroner was hugely
sympathetic with your case but had to
conclude on the evidence that he had
that Rafi was the victim of a road
traffic accident and not the victim of
an unlawful killing what's your reaction
to that
um so yes it was disappointing but we
completely understand
the decision he had to come to I mean he
had very limited information to go on so
it was kind of almost expected really do
you feel very angry though at the
failure
of the Qatari authorities to provide
information and assistance to help that
coroner that is you said
there was not really much else he could
do but to come to that verdict yes
they've had many an opportunity
we've approached them continuously our
advisor radziger has approached them
um the coroner has contacted the Qatari
authorities for information and they've
completely ignored everybody and rad
who's your your lawyer he he's written
to the foreign secretary today what was
he said and what what are you asking
them for do you want a meeting he's
calling for a meeting with the fcdo and
James cleverley to reopen this we we
want more information that we know the
qataris have and the foreign office told
us Joe that they'd offered supports in
the aftermath of rafi's death and that
they raised her case with the Qatari
authorities at a senior level is that
your experience do you know any
conversations took place so it was very
minimal and they were basically pushed
and forced to to ask for questions
um we still don't know to this day
whether
memberica hajjari has served as pitiful
two-month sentence in one uh
communication we were told yes he has
and then a week later we were told he
hadn't so we still don't have any
answers and that was the man that was
driving the car that hit hit rafi's car
yeah I want to go back to the beginning
if I may and
um Rapha your daughter and you've
described her as your best friend so
you're very very close very close and
we've got some footage that you sent in
actually which I think we can see with
of you two dancing together at home and
in Qatar there you are
um it's it's it's lovely to sit but it
must be hard to see it or work as well
um that was our apartment in Qatar
and you spent a lot of time together you
were very close and you did a lot of
dancing dancing singing laughing she'd
find something funny and everything you
and your family
are originally from there you are in the
car we're singing to Sean Paul
are you doing a bit of carpool karaoke
there yeah we loved it she knew all the
words and I just
make the noises she looks like a she
looks like she is full she is brimming
with life and having fun right
she's just an asset to the world
everybody loved her thank you for
sharing those videos and showing us Rafi
you clearly are very close
mum and daughter unit if we can let's go
back to the 30th of March 2019 that's
the day your life changed forever and it
was just a normal it was just a normal
day for you what were you and Rafi doing
that day
um so we had friends around for dinner
it's the 29th and evening we had friends
around for dinner
and rafid already arranged to go out
with a friend for coffee so she left us
about 7 30 she
said she wouldn't be late because we
were going we had like several buses
going Carmel racing the next day and she
was going to help me so she knew she had
to be back and be up early
so she left
um friends left and I went to bed and um
the morning came and it was about seven
o'clock I sat there and I thought I'll
wake her up in about an hour and as we
as was usual I always woke her up with
music so I'd walk in playing my phone
just dancing along and you know that's
how we'd start our day by quite a nice
way yeah exactly so instead of saying
come on let's go I'd sort of she loved
what Jimmy does and we'd just be silly
with each other
and so I was playing this music opened
the door and her bed was not touched I
thought that was very strange she's
either got up and left or I'm not really
sure what's happened
so I started calling her phone no reply
continuously calling her phone and I
said to Dawn have you seen RAF he hadn't
seen her
so
um it got to about nine o'clock I
started calling all of her friends I
knew I said have you seen Ralph no I
haven't seen Ralph so yeah you'll now
in quite a panic I I yeah and I said too
Don I said we need to go to the police
um I can't see you know what
you know what what could have happened
so
I um
sorry
so we went to the police and uh
walked in and they said um you know sit
down you know what's the problem so lost
my daughter here's a copy of her
passport on my phone is a photograph
sit down so we had to sit down wait wait
half an hour then mumbling to each other
um half an hour goes by I said look can
you tell us what we need to do you know
I don't know where she is
um this touring and throwing went on for
a best part of three or four hours we
waited there until about probably about
four o'clock so we'd been there a good
six six and a half hours getting nowhere
and I just turned it on and I said I
think we need to go and go to the
hospital I think we need to go and start
exploring ourselves because they're
obviously not going to help us
they either know something or they you
know they're completely incompetent so
then you leave the police station then
you start going so the city's hospital
we go to Hamad Hospital
and
um walk to the front desk and I said you
know we're looking for this person I
have a photograph of her passport on my
phone
so we're looking for this person the
lady shrugs her shoulders and kind of
points me to accident and emergency
and so we walked a little bit further
back and there was a doctor who just
taken over that shift
and I said look can you help us please
we're trying to find somebody I don't
know where we're supposed to go the lady
on reception isn't helping she may or
may not be in this hospital but the
police can't help me and he was you know
a very kind doctor and he allowed us to
look through
so here allowed us to look through the
um
entry log
and it various names of people and then
it had
a one entry it said one female
um unknown
DOA and then it was
um one
20 a.m something like that my husband
remembers the right time
and uh so I said what what does DOA mean
and he said it's Dead on Arrival
a nice I thought no that that just can't
be her I mean everybody she had a
passport with her you wouldn't be an
unknown female
we you know we had our um all sorts of
means of communicating with her and you
know it wouldn't be an unknown person
um so
after having kind of exhausted
everything there I said well I feel the
only thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to walk around the hospital myself
because if it's not an emergency entry
then it's possibly you know she's broken
her leg or something I'm not really sure
so I'm gonna walk and I walked all the
way around the hospital literally
peeling sheets I'm really sorry I'm
looking for my daughter have you seen
this person have you seen this person
that was probably about two hours of
walking around yeah around myself and my
husband we were just walking around
going I'm really sorry I'm really sorry
uh nobody had seen her
um and then we we sat in the reception
going okay well what do we do now and we
both looked at each other and went
let's eliminate that entry in the book
um and and then we'll go home and then
figure out what our next plan of action
is so um
we walked to the mortuary
um I opened the door and there was a
doctor writing in the book and she had a
photocopy of my daughter's passport next
to her
goodness
and I I just started panicking I said
why why have you got my daughter's why
have you got a photograph of my
daughter's passport
and uh I I I've repeated this so many
times that I've never seen somebody so
cold and dismissive in my life she kind
of looked up and said
Britannia you know British in Arabic and
I said yes and
indicated to the steel drawers and said
you know you want to see
and uh
sorry I'll try out
and so she walked us over to the
steel drawers just opened
draw out
okay you back the plastic
and there's
my daughter's body
foreign
for this
and um sorry I'm so sorry James I'm
completely unprepared for this and I I
didn't get
you know any amount of compassion
whatsoever neither of us know what to do
at this point we both Frozen
um
and I'm
you know I don't know whether I fell
down I don't know what I did I just the
whole world started spinning
and
I'm looking at wrath I started stroking
her head
and I kept saying my mother should go
through this
um
so um
we kind of looked her and she kind of
went his paper
I know what we're supposed to do with
that
go to the police and collect her things
it was unbelievably
cold
oh Joe I'm so sorry
um
and that and that's the beginning of a
three and a half year merry-go-rounder
we've been no answers
when did it become clear to you that
they were not investigating fully or
competently what had happened to Rafi on
that night
immediately right
because there's cameras on every single
corner of every street in Doha and Qatar
so they know exactly what's going on
everywhere and then what happened
with the man that was driving the car
that that struck
Rafi it took a long time for the
prosecutors to go after this person
so he was eventually convicted of
fleeing the scene causing death
dangerous driving and was given
two months which we have no evidence
that he's ever done and I think it was
just paying I think they just wanted to
blockade us and just go well you know
okay we've done something for you now go
away so he was given two months you have
no idea whether he even served that
uh how did you feel when that verdict
was announced it pulled appalled he was
driving 120 miles an hour
um and then he fled the sea and fled the
scene but they have a two-tier legal
system there's one for qataris and one
for everybody else now had that been a
foreign National he had been locked up
immediately and Joe
what does the experience of what
you had you had your experience in the
aftermath of rafi's death
tell you about Qatari Society
you you were happy there and then
obviously after this happened I can't
stay there I can't be here yeah
so I saw a very ugly side to the place
very ugly
um
you you get kind of undercurrents of you
know behave and um you know you're
welcome here if you say anything out of
place or if you criticize the government
or if you could criticize their mayor
then you are definitely in trouble so I
always was aware of the fact that we had
to respect the country and I always did
um but then once this happened
um we saw a completely different side to
the place
and
now billions of us what you know around
the world are watching the World Cup and
we're seeing Qatar host that World Cup
it's a huge moment for the country when
you see British sports and icons like
David Beckham promoting Qatar or perhaps
trying to put a gloss on the country's
image
what do you think what do you think how
does it make you feel
it's all about money all these people
paid Qatar buys everything it wants
including people
so
people name their price and they go out
there and they do what they're told and
that's you know a lot of expats are
being paid quite well and won't speak
there as well because it is all about
Money Money Talks if anyone watching
this tonight is thinking of visiting the
country to see it for themselves what
would what would your advice to them be
so many people do go and visit and
nothing happens to them but you do need
to be aware of certain things that as
somebody who's lived in the country a
new her way around for us not to be able
to get
any justice or any form of closure then
I have no idea how anybody visiting
would ever be able to get any support
um
so go there with your eyes wide open
uh
yeah I think you know that we've come to
a time in our Evolution where we need to
kind of
call these people to account and go no
we're not we're not going to tolerate
this you know you can't do this to
people anymore that's you know we're in
2022
they're not in the medieval area where
we go around doing what we want to
people everybody's accountable for their
actions
and you can't put on a world
event like the World Cup and then
expects you know people to be treated so
appallingly okay and thank you Joe thank
you I know it's not easy thanks for
talking Tom thank you thank you thank
you very much
Joe's story there while we did reach out
to the Qatari government and the Qatar
Embassy in London to get their view on
the case but they did not respond
the foreign office however told us we
have provided support to the family of a
woman who died in Qatar in 2019 and
raised her case with the Qatari
authorities at a senior level We Stand
ready to offer further Consular
assistance as appropriate